il va être question d d'eric zemmour je
sais que vous l'adorez à m sila le 5
novembre prochain il va se rendre à
béziers pour présenter son livre et sa
venue a notamment été annoncé par une
photo assez surprenante posté par robert
ménard bavure le maire de béziers
regardez c'est ouf
robert ménard le maire de béziers qui
créent régulièrement la polémique a
décidé d'inviter dans sa ville un autre
compère de polémique le journaliste eric
zemmour sur twitter le maire proches des
courants d'extrême droite a annoncé
peinture à l'appui la venue de son ami
et la venue du polémiste dans la ville
crée le débat beaucoup se demandent
pourquoi les deux hommes s'amusent à
mettre de l'huile sur le feu avec les
bonnes ventes de son dernier livre suite
aux différents dérapages lors de sa
promotion eric zemmour nous apporte
peut-être un élément de réponse alors
c'est la troisième fois qu'eric zemmour
répond à l'invitation de son ami robert
ménard quai pour rappel le maire béziers
bien sûr il est élue elle est élue avec
ce soutien du fn et rohmer berbère
bénard a posté aujourd'hui donc un tweet
pour annoncer la venue d'eric zemmour à
béziers avec une photo du polémiste en
astérix
voilà c'est ça ça s'est arrangé pour
astérix ans qu'est-ce qui se passe
ce n'est pas gentil pour aspirer il
espère que les héritiers d'astérix
voulait qu'on l'emporté aussi gilbert d
une honteuse récupération politique
c'est une confusion des genres vous me
dites souvent liberté d'expression mais
là non pas ça à quoi s'est effectivement
s'est embrasé une ville qui est déjà
compliquée
quel est l'intérêt que c'est moi et là
bas c'est que de la provocation moi j'en
ai marre jma ce qui n'est plus le droit
de s'exprimer joint alors amélie un
moment il faudra passer par là vous êtes
d'accord avec iranian cinq minutes lui
que le trou
oui je parle de l'écrit au charme et sa
gueule c'est fermer sa gueule cinq
minutes le talent fou et je vous dise
son livre les ressorts du perrier ghachi
quand il ya des théories qu'il n'y a que
lui qui arrive à les comprendre c'est
voilà c'est ça rend pas service au pays
non alors je vous dise olive cartonne
voilà donc il a rien sans rien
médiatique puisque destin français se
classe en tête des ventes
il dépasse même le dernier roman
d'amélie nothomb voilà donc forcément et
ben il va continuer à eric zemmour
puisque ça cartonne c'est vrai ça
cartonne pour lui et c'est vrai que tous
les buzz qu'il fait mine de rien lui
permettre de vendre son livre derrière
et le livre d'avant aussi avait-elle et
non non non
car c'est après le brésil on n'a plus
peur de rien maintenant c'est vrai merci
bernard montant n'est pas le tout seul à
penser ce qu'ils pensent bas autant je
vais j'y vais je n'achète pas pour le
brûler non mais j'ai aussi passé ce qui
aidera match est intéressant aussi
même nous on pense parce qu'il pense
qu'on aurait pu l'acheter pour voir un
petit peu quand même
il ya eu un tel buzz que tu as envie de
vous lire et à ce qu'il va dire mais
c'est vrai que je n'ai pas acheté non
plus une fois là je vous me connaissez